who does not want to hear what you have
to say
most people don't want to hear what you
have to say okay now why is most people
not wanting to have
hear what you have to say
when a kid is being raised you got a
good cop in a bad cop right
the
in many instances
the father's a bad cop many instances in
the family nucleus where mom and dad are
together the father plays the bad cop
the father comes in get your [ __ ]
together you ain't doing nothing be a
man go make money get off your ass all
you're doing is this all you're doing is
that and that's the message
however
if the market is only filled with only
one or the of the two it's not healthy
meaning if it's only take given this
message that's not healthy if it's only
the mom saying well leave him alone
andrew you're being too tough on him you
don't know what he's going through he's
just a kid he's 12 years old why are you
being so tough on him and you the father
i'm trying to turn him into a man he
needs to be man you realize how talk the
world but baby's just a kid babe leave
him alone you don't know what happened
with him last week so then you as the
father goes to sleep
and
you tell her you didn't hear anything
she said but you sitting there saying
maybe she's got a point maybe she's got
a point and in the morning you go to the
kid and say no matter how much [ __ ] i
talk and i challenge you guess what i
love you i believe in you i think you
can do something special with your life
but i want to see you be a leader right
so to mark the problem with the market
is
they only want to give mommy's message
completely without daddy's message this
is why i believe this message blew up
because the market needs this as well
because so what happens when i listen to
andrew's message you go you'll say
something you know what like we met a
lady of yours that you introduced to us
yesterday he said this is my wife and we
met her right and you said i'm not in a
phase where i want to have thousands if
i wanted to i could every night i could
have a different girl
all that stuff you say we say for me
it's only five okay five's the magic
number and you say five's the number
okay so you say that and
is it satire is it real is it straight
up are you just saying it because you
still want to poke a little bit you
still don't want to lose the ability to
poke yeah or is it that's really what i
do want to do you know i do want to kind
of have five wives because there's a
leak in that argument as well if you
take that angle of saying i want a 5i
five wives no completely and and that's
a good point and that's
that's an interesting one as well
because i had a conversation with um
with a journalist from the telegraph who
came to my house and i had a long
conversation with him which i'm about to
raise before that i just want to quickly
say something that you reminded me of
earlier
i think that one of the main reasons
people hate me is because my message is
one of the fact that i came from
absolutely nothing i never had a
privileged upbringing in any regard and
i became exactly what i wanted to be and
if you subscribe to my message and
you're a fat unhappy man then you know
all of the failures are your own i'm a
reflection i am saying that if you
understand how i think and my world you
could have become anything you want to
be but you're unhappy with who you are
and that is your fault so the people who
hate me sit there and go well if he's
right then i [ __ ] up if he's right i
could have been anyone i wanted to be
and i [ __ ] up so he can't be right he
has to be wrong because this is not my
fault this is the fault of whatever i
had an unlucky upbringing or my girl
left me or that it's someone else's
fault if i take responsibility like tate
tells me then i'm a fuck-up right so i
have to hate kate has to be wrong and
that's why if you look at the general
the composition of my haters i'm talking
about their physical composition as
people you can just look at the people
he likes tate he hates yeah he likes to
she likes hate she she wants to go on
tape to y'all she she can't stand his
ass she like it's very easy to see
physically you can just look at their
faces yep yep yep yep no yeah no you can
see it right because it's all about
personal responsibility which is why i
teach and that's why a lot of people
hate me
so that that's the first thing i'll talk
about reflection but it's very
interesting what you're saying about the
five lives thing
part of what i do
when i talk especially about my personal
life to a degree is subversion
i learned this my father was a chess
grandmaster right
and he uh i used to travel around
america with him and he'd play chess and
back then there was a lot of former kgb
guys
who played chess in these massive
tournaments and when they spoke they
were very subversive
you he'd introduced you to his
girlfriend and she'd be his wife and
then his other girlfriend she's his wife
and then his friend is his daughter they
just say things that aren't really true
another thing they do is they're very
very emotive with their hands
which is a habit that i kind of learned
sometimes so if if they were sitting
there and an argument got kind of heated
they'd begin to move their hands along
as they just disagreed listen to me
listen
and they move their hands because then
you can't see even
so they start to move their hands and
you get used to and then whack right so
there's a few things i picked up from
them but there's a degree of subversion
so if i sit and say i have five wives or
ten wives or one wife or no wife
i like that the matrix doesn't
completely understand
why i have that's that's one of the main
reasons i do it the second thing is this
i sat there with a reporter
from the telegraph who said that why
would you have five wives if you cheat
on them they're unhappy
and i said my friend
who are you to tell women
how they feel and what decisions they
want to make
how insulting of you how how's
chauvinistic
are you to sit and say that women do not
have the independent thought to decide i
am prepared to share the top g because
of his qualities and accolades and
financial capability
as opposed for you to sit here and say
they're not allowed to think that they
have to think what we believe they
should think what the matrix tells them
they should think there are plenty of
beautiful women out there who will say
you know what a man like him
he might do this and that on the side
but you know what
he's my man there's women who will think
that they won't think it for a [ __ ]
loser but they'll certainly think at the
top when chris brown walks in the club
and all the girls start screaming do you
think they're going yes he'll be loyal
[ __ ] no he's chris brown they don't give
a [ __ ] because of his status at a
certain status of man i'm not saying
that men should cheat i'm not saying
these things i'm saying at a certain
status of man the idea of absolute
exclusivity and absolute loyalty becomes
less important to the female because of
his other accolades
that's that's a fact every king every
sultan read the bible every warlord had
a bunch of women why excuse the warlord
the [ __ ] [ __ ] muncher didn't but the
warlord did that's just the way that we
made that distinction by the way it
wasn't just the topic it's just to talk
and i'm not saying that all men can do
it but that's also my message
i don't comment i don't say to all men
have a bunch of girls i don't say that i
say you better become the [ __ ] man
all i can tell you is what it's like up
here and how i got here if you're
telling me you're adamant on staying
down there then don't cry that you're
lonely because i don't know that life i
can't tell you so once again
i took about five wise four hours
whatever etcetera these feminists who
attack me saying he has he gets these
women and he cheats on the
if a female decides she wants to be with
me
assuming that's what i even do i could
be mr monogamous if anyone [ __ ] knows
right assuming that's what i do that's
her imperative she's an adult she can
sit there and go okay my man's the big
boss and he's with me 99 the time but i
know if he goes to moscow on a business
trip he's doing x but he comes home to
me and i'm driving to bentley and i'm
happy that's her impress that's her
imperative that's her prerogative it's
only the feminists and the [ __ ]
people who care so much about misogyny
and love the women so much who come
along and say women are allowed to think
for themselves no they're not allowed to
accept that they can accept whatever
they want women are the gatekeepers it's
a it's a free market and women are the
gatekeepers women have all the choice if
they want to get a guy who doesn't
thought nothing else don't be they can
go get some other guy women have all the
options in the world so if if
last week i was on my yacht in croatia
there's me my brother and like 30 girls
all the girls were getting messages why
are you there i want to be here
i want to be honest i'm not being
helpful
not against my will that's their
decision to make how arrogant and
narcissistic must you be as a random
individual especially a male a random
unattractive male with no girlfriend to
message an attractive woman and tell her
that what she's doing she thinks wrong
for being with me and my brother out of
yaw and that she should instead want him
playing video games at home
what kind of level of delusion are you
operating under to even believe that
that's a paradigm of reality and these
are the people who dislike me who then
get exposed to being pedophiles like
dad's black so it's it's just absolutely
insane i i'm sorry to keep rambling but
i want to talk with one more thing i
will talk about one more thing because
it's really important
they say i'm a threat to women
which is absolutely not the truth it
couldn't be further from the truth and i
want to say two things about that
i can't think of another person who
raised who had reached fame as
meteorically as me who never had a
single i've not i've yet to have a
single woman come out and accuse me of
rape
sexual assault try and get money from me
none
i have a long and varied history
with females and not a single one
despite i now have hundreds of millions
of dollars has come forward now that
those famous man in the world despite
the newspapers finding them online
finding extras i haven't spoken to for
years calling them and offering them 25
grand for a story bribe to turn on me
not one of them has decided to turn on
me in life for money
not one
and that could have very easily happened
to me it would have been a nail in one
of the coffins if that would have
happened to me luckily none of it did
because i'm a gentleman and these women
know that what's happening to me is
[ __ ] not a single one has come
forward against me but i'm somehow i'm a
threat to women i would argue that most
men in my position have that in meteoric
rise one of their stupid exes would go
[ __ ] this guy yeah i'll take the money
and start talking [ __ ] i would argue
that happened to a lot of men never
happened to me it's the first thing the
second thing i want to argue is when
they send my threat to women if i have
choice
why would i be a threat
the threat to women is the man with no
access to women these people who want to
do these videos these unattractive
objectively unattractive unsuccessful
people who do take down videos of me who
can't get a girlfriend he's the guy
who's gonna be a dangerous to women he's
the creep i have choices if a girl says
to me i don't like you no problem thank
god one less whatsapp conversation
goodbye have a nice life nice to meet
you
it doesn't matter to me right so the men
who are successful with women are not
the dangers it's the men who are
unsuccessful with women who are the
dangers so once again the whole paradigm
is shift it's [ __ ] i have no reason
to hurt a female or rape a female or
trick a female in any regard
why would i do that if you enjoyed this
video and you want to watch the entire
podcast click over here and if you want
to be connected with experts influencers
such as kiyosaki tate connolly
parliamentary myself and others download
the app minect where you get a chance to
connect with these folks by the minute
you get to buy the minute or have face
times with them 15 minutes ask them any
questions you may want to have download
the admin act and start connecting with
influencers and experts today
[Music]